*an amazing ear rape, its lit, seriously. check it out on soundcloud.*
👏 👏
MEME REVIEW EVERYBODY! YouTube's most thought-out show.
Hey, you see this cat?
Whenever there's a new cat photo out there meow
This is going into my cat folder compilation
Finally more funny pictures of cat that I can share around and make out a memes out of (???)
How could anyone say no to this cat face? Huh?
Bruce landlord. It is clear in the lease
No pets allowed in this apartment
sumimasen
Sorry
Send a photo of the cat. Okay, I will make an exception because he looks very polite haha *sharp manly inhale*
This photo was sent out and it became an immediate cat sensation
It was a cat strophe....
ficy
Even Trump himself (Really great guy) thought wow Sugoi desu ne. Neko-chan.  Uoh Uoh Uoh
ne. Neko-chan.  Uoh Uoh Uoh
Also guys, I have a special offer for you guys in case you aren't aware
If you like this video right now do it you will die instantly hooray
Thanks to this cat what a polite little kitty
How is this a meme yo bring a friend for my home boy. Is he cute? Is he cute?
Yeah, my person cute man. So you see that's where the trouble began
I know you were trouble when you cat in
Let's just move on this mean gets a three. I don't know what to tell you. It's another picture of a cat
It's clear in the lease. No pets allowed in this apartment Jar Jar Binks. Ok. I will make an exception
He looks very polite and he is very polite. I wonder if you can grab his eyes, you know, I kind of want to like
Suck his eyes. That's not gay. It's just not gay
This is literally me when another cat makes it into cat meme compilations
Moving on do not bully people
Do not make fun of anyone what's going on guys? Today I'm gonna tell you how to get a
Absolutely incredible item from llama's behind?
Next meme is MoMA
Next me Takashi the fastest cloud sound rapper in the game
We have seen his palette. We have seen his strengths and we have seen how strong he is
But new evidence have arozen that's the word be quiet arisen that shows that he was actually much
Listen here. Come closer. He's much faster. You can add it then you can never believe what I'm about to show you is highly classified
confidential
Government protected footage of Tekeshi's 6ix9ine
. I know his name is not Tekeshi 6ix9ine
It's just easier for me to say it. (6ix9ine) "I hate when people like
Underestimate me like how fast I am a from one video
I'm fast as f***"
HE ZOOM
6ix9ine and his girlfriend but who the lady- who the lady holding his girlfriend?
Caption this when your last two brain cells meet is that woah vicky heck ya
The reason why I'm bringing up Takashi what was 6ix 9ine again is cuz he was in trouble guys. That's right
I'm starting a
GoFundMe page to save takeshi's bill of a hundred and fifty thousand bail. It's called bail he got arrested for
Skipping out on a court date to face charges that he'd choke a fan. Listen. He's a great guy. All right, so, please
let's start this GoFundMe page and see how much we can raise and I swear on my honor as a
Youtuber I will donate all the money to takeshi's bail
He needs to get out of bail if Takeshi doesn't get out of bail
I don't know what I'll do what other rappers scream extremely loud during their song
I don't know why I'm memeing this so hard. I actually like him. It seems like everyone hates him
He's just he's like a little can I say?
сгущенное молоко
Can I say?
He's like, I mean it as an endearing way. He's a cute little
сгущенное молоко
That's not bad. That's not a bad word, please. It's a wonderful word for a wonderful person
The alien is back the dame tu cosita out of the casita
The alien is back the dame tu cosita out of the cosita
The cousin of cosita is back
I don't believe it either because it's such a bad meme
Why why did this one have to come back out of all memes that can come back and make a rebound?
This is--no one asked for this who asked for this who wanted this one duper come back
I didn't hey, you know, we'll make a great meme? This metal looking alien dancing
Imagine having sleep paralysis and seeing this at the foot of the bed
Just again breaking it down and you can't do anything about it.
Like you hear the music in the bag and everything
Bruh
That is one of the most horrifying experience
I could ever imagine
Now I want sleep paralysis, oh, there it is
My god, I am terrified right now. It went from funny cute lil' meme to
savage heart in an instant
これはいいアニメです
This metal alien is literally everywhere
Recarnation of Brad 3
I love this show. This is one of my fav-
NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Content RestrICTED
IT was him
First time I laugh at this stupid meme which is one more time than anyone ever will
Imagine having sleep paralysis
and seeing
PewDiePie at the foot of the bed just breaking it down and you can't do anything about it like
You hear the music in the back and everything?
What you get a 1 like what is this who is here before PewDiePie meme reviews it
I already had it in the Dame tu cosita Oh Oh, what is this Oh, what is that?
Cool over a month ago
interesting
Come on fellow meme -sters. Hi. I know you're watching this game steams
Streaming. Oh my
The meme scenes
Ain't nobody got time for that. The meme scenes
Success Xfinity presents the meme steam their names Dean is crazy. You're so fat
Ain't nobody got time for that
Sorry
Xfinity, where do I sign them?
Finally a company that gets it
It's like I love memes so much like I'm a memer I would I would actually consider myself a memer, okay
Finally like I can pay money to this company. I
Love the mean scenes. They're just like honestly, they're better than these goddamn dancing alien at least
Oh
My god, what is the last one?
Is it?
Are they going to confirm the alien dancing guys?
The Nostalgia having this soundtrack, I love this meme it's so good
great editing
Great power. It makes me feel good. It makes me feel great and lifts me up
See your body is 70% water and daddys thirsty. Someone made this I
Mean, I'm not one to talk. I'm sure there's some pretty bad - out there dude. I love it
it's
Coming home
It's coming home is it as soon as Sweden lost against England people just couldn't stop tweeting at me. Oh
You won against Sweden, you know, that means nothing right? Oh, it's coming up AM everybody. Oh it's coming over
It's gonna be so great. KSI. ugh i hate that guy mocking me on Twitter
Disgusting even trying to threaten my own show meme review he changed he changed the title
It was meme reviewing the type he know as soon as England lot
This was called its coming home meme review. How dare he try to steal my show and then
England lost and boom meme review deleted suddenly the meme isn't so funny now, isn't it?
Because this England is coming home. It's not coming home. It's going home. And please stay there, England
I mean, I'm in England right now. What doesn't matter shut up. This video is really funny now after England lost
It's not your you're going home like everyone else
No one likes you. No one likes Sweden either. I don't know why I have nothing to boast about
You know what? I like to do the most in the whole world. I like to grab a monster energy drink not sponsor
I like to crack that open
Fire up my
Playstation 4 Pro and I like to hold it like this and the first the first set the saliva in my mouth is already
And then I fire up World of Tanks and I'm ready and then that's how I know
I'm living if you're not sipping on a monster drink, then you ain't living Center. That's right
I'm almost 30 years old and I review memes. What can I say?
We're a classful bunch of people that likes to sip on a drink a drink that doesn't does just doesn't represent
Capitalism it represents what the world could be
While you kids you have your Takashi
6-9. We are sipping our way
When our Monster energy drinks and I feel bad
you know whenever I see someone that isn't sipping on a monster energy drink it upsets me because
I have so much empathy in my heart and in my soul, like if you ain't zipping you ain't livin
It really doesn't taste get
All the memes were garbage this week. Well, do you think that's my fault?
I'm just reviewing them meme review leave a like if you enjoyed this video guys
appreciate all the support and
Namaste, thank you guys and as always
*clap clap* (Bring Back Bonus MEME)